what's up everybody it's warren welcome
back to the cosmic wonder i have today
with me culture chris from cosmic
culture if you're not subscribed to him
be sure to do so we just got back to our
hotel room
from the venom let there be carnage
premiere big thank you to sony and g
fuel for having us out giving us the
invite super appreciate it guys you're
not ready for for what you're going to
see
in this movie
you're not you're not ready for it the
movie is action-packed
we were just talking i think my favorite
part is cletus cassidy oh woody
harrelson knocked it out of the park
if you're excited to see carnage be
excited to see cletus cassidy as well
because i mean it's weird helsing he's
he's amazing
we need to say nothing else yeah and
they did do a great job highlighting
exactly what you just said cletus no
he's in and out of carnage right and
it's a blast and he's a psychopath and
like he really is a psychopath
like in the film a very believable
carnage right we can't talk about
anything in details because obviously
the movie has not come out yet and we
don't want to give any spoilers but
but the posters
but here's the post but here's exactly
what happened
and sony sued us no uh but the
post-credits scene uh
[Laughter]
it's it's it's really important
and it's like
like like really it's like everyone was
clapping
so hard after that post credit scene i
will say we only saw one
uh there wasn't two there was only one
mid credit scene i'll also say
with all the rumors and everything out
you might think you know what we're
talking about
you actually don't it's true you
actually don't know what you think you
know yeah it's true um it was definitely
different and i was like oh
it's different
i was actually kind of shocked so
going into that because i'm you watch my
channel you watch leagues everything
like that if you're here you know what
you know what you want
but really it was it was so
the post-credits scene was so good
it it implies a lot and it's different
than what i was expecting like it's
actually really different and it poses a
lot of questions a lot of very important
questions and i think sony you know
they've been advertising the universe 6
is expanding
but not how you thought it was
but also yes in a very exciting way yeah
yeah so i mean if you're excited for
carnage you're going to go see the movie
and you're going to love the movie
i thought it was a good movie i i did um
i i unfortunately think a lot of people
are going to be talking about the post
credits more than they are about the
movie but i mean
the movie did what the movie was
dude it was funny like it's it's funny
stepped up it's comedy from yeah it
definitely stopped this comedy people
were laughing a lot and i think it might
not be so many people's humor but i
actually thought it was pretty funny it
actually really explored the
relationship between venom and eddie
really well
actually like really really well um i
think dan's kind of a hero
unexpected champion back to your hero
and uh even gets a little bit of props
like there was
it did what it was supposed to do it was
a venom
versus carnage movie and again i think
to me
i think what harrelson's cletus cassidy
was like that was the highlight to me it
was that was like insane and i've gotta
say specifically
i wouldn't when i first saw him you know
with the wig
i was confused not even because of the
wig just because of the actor of the
casting from the post credits
i genuinely was i was like
[Music]
i repent
i apologize for doubting no you killed
it i love tom hardy obviously that's
great as venom but
woody harrelson did an insanely good job
really really good job so guys go see it
even if you're not interested in the
movie go see it
for the post-credits scene you need to
go see it you need to experience it
again a big thank you to sony and g fuel
for having us out it was really really
awesome thanks for the the super awesome
cooler g-fuel and we have the g-fuel
carnage
and venom g-fuel if you're a fan of
g-full you can use code cosmic for a
discount on their site or you can find
them like 7-eleven near you but again
thinking about this for having us out
this awesome night we saw a lot of
people like the knowing bros tayden
miller soups brad lambert a lot of
really awesome people there overall
great experience go watch venomotherby
carnage and be ready for that post
credit scene so he says warren
chris chris
go subscribe to cosmic culture
and i will catch you guys next time woof